this episode was supported by brilliant
org hey crazies it's time to tackle my
favorite paradox of all time the twins
paradox unfortunately I don't have any
twins even though everyone keeps asking
but I do have clones
I'd like to introduce you to rocket
clone hi he's super useful for this sort
of thing to infinity and beyond yeah
whatever just get in the rocket okay
let's do with this rocket clone zips off
with 55% the speed of light - I don't
know let's say both three five nine
which is a modest eight light-years away
by the way for those of you who don't
know a Lightyear is not a time it's a
speed times a time a Lightyear is a
distance
anyway rocket clone gets to look three
five nine and immediately turns around
when he finally gets back to the station
twenty nine years have gone by for me
but only twenty four years have gone by
for him if you're even remotely familiar
with relativity this isn't that
surprising rule number two for
relativity says every observer carries
their own set of coordinates and their
own clock I get a clock you'll get a
clock everybody gets a clock different
observers traveling different paths
through space time are gonna measure
different amounts of time there's no
paradox there a quick way to calculate
the difference is by using something
called the gamma factor it's a number
that shows up all over relativity so get
used to seeing using that factor I
expected rocket clone to be only twenty
four years older even though I'm 29
years older there's no surprise on my
end
rocket clone is the one that surprised
rule number four says it will always
look to an observer as though they're
stationary in space as far as Rocket
clone is concerned he stayed in one
place and I'm the one that moved we also
have rule number one no point of view
has preference over any other point of
view rocket clone is the one with the
paradox he aged 24 years and if he does
the same calculation I did he expects to
find me only 20 years older not 29 years
older he expects to be the older one
paradox huh
not sure why that happened I've said it
before and I'll say it again paradoxes
are not a problem of the universe
they're a problem of the human mind the
universe doesn't have a problem we do
when it comes to paradoxes there are
only two ways we could have made a
mistake option one we've made an
assumption we shouldn't have made
meaning one of the rules we used isn't
actually a rule it's difficult to argue
with rule number four since perception
is pretty self centered and rule number
two can't be a problem since that's what
relativity is all about that leaves only
rule number one so let's take a closer
look at that throwing out rule number
one is a very common way people try to
solve this paradox but that unravels the
entirety of relativity I mean do you
think I would have spent an entire video
giving you a list of rules for
relativity that could break in
relativity don't be ridiculous
it's rule number one for crying out loud
anyway here's how the typical
explanation goes since rocket cologne
accelerates he feels a force toward the
back of his rocket a force of uniform
gravity to be specific this breaks the
symmetry between his clock and minds
somehow making mind the correct clock
but here's the problem with that
solution there never was any symmetry
between him and me to begin with like we
said earlier different observers
traveling different paths through
space-time are gonna measure different
amounts of time and that's not just true
of time it's also true of distance
length and a whole list of other
measurements having one of the observers
accelerate just adds another measurement
to the list of things they disagree on
forces are now on the list it's not that
significant of a change it certainly
doesn't make one person write in another
person wrong it just makes them more
relative but don't accelerated points of
view or acquire general relativity yes
but general relativity fixed that by
strengthening rule number one not
throwing it away rule number one holds
in general relativity just as much as it
does in special relativity the fact that
rocket Clun accelerates isn't the
problem then what other mistake could we
have made I'm so glad you asked option
two we didn't consider something we
should have considered I feel like
there's something missing here one two
four-oh it's rule number three we forgot
rule number three we have to use the
correct coordinate transformation
remember this quick calculation rocket
clone did its wrong and this quick
calculation I did also wrong but didn't
you get the right answer yeah but that's
well okay maybe maybe wrong was a bit
harsh let's go in sloppy when we do this
we get no perspective on what we're
calculating the number rocket clone
calculated is valid it's just not the
answer to the question he was asking
you're not always calculating what you
think you're calculating it's safer to
use the full transformations or better
yet written in matrix form because you
transform both space and time together
it gives you a better idea of what
you're looking at but you know what
works even better a spacetime diagram if
you're not familiar with those you
should go watch this video first it'll
also help with all these rules I've been
giving you so in the twins paradox the
two paths look like this rocket clone
accelerates away from the space station
reaches 55 percent the speed of light
and stops accelerating he eventually
gets the Wolf 359 turns around and the
whole thing happens in Reverse the
straight paths are constant velocity the
curved paths are the accelerations so
yes there are three sections where
rocket clone is accelerating but like I
said before the fact that rocket clone
accelerates isn't the problem this
paradox does not require accelerations
it persists even if rocket clone goes to
the same velocity the whole time these
are the lengths of the two space-time
paths 29 years in 24 years if we're
going to remove all of the accelerations
though then we can't even let rocket
clone turn around that means these are
the numbers we expect to see 14 and a
half years and 12 years because we're
only looking at half the trip okay now
let's look at the simplified diagram say
rocket clone is already going 55% the
speed of light when he flies past my
space station some time later he passes
Wolf 359 he just keeps going because no
accelerations I say rocket clones path
is about 14 and a half years tall but he
says it's about 12 years tall it
actly half the time differences from
earlier because this is half the trip so
this is totally consistent with
everything we got before the paradox
arose when we tried to look the other
way
starting from rocket clones coordinates
we can look back at me and wait a minute
we're not looking at rocket clones path
anymore we're looking at mine that's a
completely different space-time path hmm
rocket clones path measured in rocket
clones coordinates is 12 years tall but
that only includes a portion of my path
a portion that's about ten years tall
and my coordinates exactly half the time
difference from earlier because this is
half the trip but that doesn't actually
say anything about my path in space-time
it's only saying things about his path
which isn't the question he was asking
the event of rocket clone passing Wolf
359 isn't on my path it's on his to line
that up with the event at the end of my
path rocket clone has to wait over five
more years because my entire path is
almost 17 and a half years tall in his
coordinates these horizontal grid lines
are lines of equal time that's seventeen
and a half years is the number rocket
clone should have used to calculate my
time using that sloppy calculation from
earlier except he wouldn't have known to
do that that extra five years doesn't
even exist in the full twins paradox
because by then rocket clone would have
turned around he wouldn't even be on
that path anymore so here's the real
problem both of us are trying to
calculate the location and the time of
an event on someone else's path in
someone else's coordinates there are
four different measurements here two
different paths measured in two
different coordinates everyone agrees if
those measurements are taken at the same
place at the same time because we can
just take the measurement together but
if they're at different places we have a
problem at different locations those
numbers are just predictions not
measurements each of us has to take a
measurement of ourselves maybe one
selfie every day and then send it to the
other person and it's a whole other can
of worms that I'd rather not open my
point is this the acceleration doesn't
make one of the time measurements
incorrect it's just that without the
acceleration we only get one shared
event the
raishin gives us a second shared event
if we don't want to deal with sending
selfies to each other then we need to
shared events to measure the passage of
time one at the beginning and one at the
end we can't agree at any other events
we might want to include so we can't
compare measurements between them the
acceleration doesn't give anyone
priority
it just fixes a measurement problem you
don't have to throw out rule number one
if you do rule number three correctly
the twins paradox disappears entirely if
you remember all the rules of relativity
so are you satisfied with the solution
please discuss in the comments thanks
for liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us hit that notification
bell if you really like what we do here
and until next time remember it's okay
to be a little crazy still feeling like
you need some practice then check out
brilliant org brilliant is a
problem-solving website designed to
train you to think like a scientist on a
wide variety of topics if you like this
video then you'll probably like their
course on relativity anyone who is new
to relativity might want to check out
reference frames and observers it gives
you that traditional introduction using
the Lorentz transformations
you know these equations here once you
feel comfortable you can check out
space-time and paradoxes where you hone
your skills using space-time diagrams
that's where the true power of
relativity lies they even have a quiz on
the twins paradox they do talk about
acceleration in there but will forgive
them brilliant was nice enough to
sponsor this video and crazy enough to
offer you a discount the first 72 people
to visit brilliant dot org will get 20%
off an annual premium subscription it's
a really good offer if you're interested
in getting some extra practice several
of you were disappointed I didn't do a
spacetime diagram for the two ships
moving away from each other there's a
reason for that you can calculate
relative speeds using angles in a
spacetime diagram but their hyperbolic
angles which means you need hyperbolic
trig it's a kind of math I wasn't
interested in explaining in that video
anyway thanks for watching